[Música]
y comenzamos a hablar de economía aquí
en france24 y para eso nos acompaña
jorge hurtado jorge bienvenido y
empecemos con el dato en eeuu donde se
duplicó la inflación así bueno la tasa
interanual de inflación en eeuu se
moderó levemente en abril hasta el 83 %
estos dos décimas por debajo de la de
marzo pero aún está bastante elevada en
comparación con el 42 % de abril del año
pasado ahí los costos de la energía
aumentaron un 30,3 por ciento en los
últimos 12 meses mientras la gasolina es
43 6% más cara que hace un año para
entender cómo se explica esta
desaceleración es una buena una mala
noticia conversamos antes con juan david
valencia víctor de análisis y estrategia
de casa de bolsa esto dijo pero
efectivamente la inflación muestra una
desaceleración respecto al mes pasado y
hay algo que no es tan positivo es que
el dato sale levemente por encima lo que
estaban esperando los analistas sin
embargo en medio de todo no siguió
aumentando
y lo que explica en gran medida este
dato es que hay un efecto estadístico ya
en contra es decir la inflación venía
siendo ya tan alta que es muy difícil
que siga subiendo al mismo ritmo al que
lo venía haciendo entonces al momento de
presentar en términos mensuales un leve
descenso en términos anuales eso
representa lo que vimos en el caso del
dato reportado el día de hoy una
desaceleración clara en eeuu también hay
temores en una recesión económica por el
alza de los precios un problema que dejó
la pandemia y que al grado que se agravó
con la guerra en ucrania sobre esto
comentó nuestro invitado bueno desde
casa de bolsa estamos viendo que la
probabilidad de una recesión en eeuu se
ha venido elevando con el tiempo vimos
el pib y en el primer trimestre muy
flojo eso va a terminar contribuyendo en
cierta medida que esa expectativa de
inflación se vayan reduciendo con con el
tiempo y de hecho se lo que estamos
viendo está generando volatilidad los
mercados en estos momentos que a pesar
que el dato método fue relativamente
positivo porque la inflación no subió
vemos unas acciones que siguen
vélez cayendo para la sesión del día de
hoy y unos tres oros americanos que
ceden levemente caen demente se valoriza
como activo refugio jorge y cambiamos de
tema porque las aerolíneas gol y avianca
y anunciaron un acuerdo para crear un
holding de transporte aéreo de qué se
trata se llamará grupo ahora y estará
controlado por los principales
accionistas de las empresas que se unen
este nuevo grupo busca hacer la
competencia directa de la tanque es la
más grande hasta ahora en américa latina
aseguran que otros inversores pondrán
350 millones de dólares tras el cierre
del acuerdo que se espera concluye en la
segunda mitad de este año para entender
el impacto de este acuerdo conversamos
con enrique perrella el es editor de la
revista airways esto nos dijo
es una tendencia que hemos visto en los
últimos años no solamente en américa
sino también en europa en europa podemos
tomar el ejemplo del del consorcio de
british airways que está allí tienen a
iberia tiene una crítica de weiss línea
vueling tienen aer lingus y es un
conglomerado bastante grande que han
decidido mantener sus marcas separadas y
es lo mismo que va a ser avianca con gol
y conviva va a ser un consorcio de tres
aerolíneas totalmente
separadas con tres culturas diferentes
con tres marcas y con tres formas de
operar diferentes pero es una fusión que
les va a ayudar a hacer más eficientes
no solamente en poder vender boletos a
sus clientes sino también van a tener un
poder de decisión y poder de influencia
mucho más grande ante los fabricantes al
momento de comprar aviones y al momento
de ofrecer más opciones a sus clientes
entonces pienso que es una
oportunidad tanto para ellos
posicionarse mejor en el mercado
latinoamericano y también para sus sus
compradores sus clientes los pasajeros
del día a día van a tener más opciones
de viajar
en latinoamérica que nunca ha sido tan
fácil y al ellos consolidar estas tres
aerolíneas que son bastante importantes
y de bastante peso pienso que puede ser
muy beneficioso tanto para las
aerolíneas como para los pasajeros otra
de las noticias es que el banco mundial
público el flujo de remesas de 2021
jorge cuéntenos cómo le fue a américa
latina bueno los envíos hacia américa
latina aumentaron 25.3 por ciento en
2021 y alcanzaron los 131 mil millones
de dólares y con mejores perspectivas
del mercado laboral en eeuu se espera
que las remesas a la región crezcan un
9% este año aunque los expertos no
descartan una tendencia a la baja por la
guerra en ucrania y los temores por una
desaceleración del crecimiento mundial
en la región los países que recibieron
mayor flujos está guatemala ecuador
honduras méxico el salvador república
dominicana colombia también se ubica a
haití y nicaragua méxico está entre los
5 países del mundo que más
transferencias recibieron en 2021 el
primer sin día el segundo es méxico y el
tercero china jorge gracias por toda
esta información y nosotros seguimos con
más en directo américa
[Música]